this is Manchester City's third
consecutive premier league title for an
incredible fifth time in six years
[Applause]
the team arrived at today's Chelsea
Clash already Champions
[Applause]
After Arsenal's loss on Saturday gave
City an unassailable lead I'd love to
have won it today and win the league but
you know the Champions champions again
three times well done because they've
done amazing already yeah we can go all
the way through the bits absolutely yeah
so we can enjoy it today really can
this was the name on many backs
Norwegian Striker erling Harland in his
first year at City broke the Premier
League record for most goals in a season
my daughter and I said he would smash
all the records if he came here and he
has and he's you know incredible
absolutely amazing love him
[Music]
what a day this has been for fans 13
Premier League champions for the third
consecutive time but the eyes on the
prize here at bogus family
[Music]
with that and the FA Cup final two
There's real belief here that City can
achieve the treble
but hanging over celebrations are
ongoing questions about whether the club
has broken premier league rules on
spending
Manchester City
face more than 100 charges from the
Premier League
um
and this is breaching of financial rules
in relation to uh inflating how much
they've been receiving and
trying to say they've spent less than
what they have because it's complicated
because they haven't won these titles
just because of the money they've spent
but clearly it gives you a huge
advantage
City denies any wrongdoing and today was
less about charges more about trophies
and this the latest addition to the
team's growing collection
Sky News of Manchester